in this video we will study about the
respiratory system the human respiratory
system is one of the most vital organ
systems of the body we've read about
16,000 to 24,000 times per day which
exchanges about 11,000 liters of air
with atmosphere in this process the
oxygen of the atmospheric air is
delivered to the human body which is
then utilized by all the tissues and the
carbon dioxide which is produced by the
human body is exported to the lungs and
then exchanged with the atmospheric air
in this video we will first talk about
the brief anatomy and physiology of the
human respiratory system then we will
discuss how the gas transport to the
Albu life occurs we will talk about how
the human respiratory system works
together with the circulatory system and
then we will talk about how the gas
exchange happens in the alveoli
so first coming to the anatomy and
physiology of the human respiratory
system the vocal cords present in the
larynx divide the respiratory tract into
the upper respiratory tract and the
lower respiratory tract and the upper
respiratory tract contains structures
like the nasal cavity the pharynx and
the part of the larynx above the vocal
cords the lower respiratory tract starts
with the part of the larynx below the
vocal folds trachea bronchi bronchioles
as well as the alveoli so let's first
talk about the brief anatomy of the nose
and the nasal cavity now if we take a
look at this diagram in a bit detail we
can see that the nasal cavity is made up
of a roof which is in turn made up of
the bones forming the base of the skull
it also consists of a floor which is
made up of the palatine bones the main
job of the nose and the nasal cavity in
the respiratory tract is the filtration
of air this is made possible by small
minut hair light structures present in
the nasal cavity called cilia the
filtration of air is also facilitated by
the mucus which is secreted by the nasal
walls this traps dust pullins as well as
other pollutants present in the
atmospheric air the other job that the
nozzle cavity performs is warming and
humidification of the air which prevents
the dryness in the respiratory membranes
oral cavity also serves as a secondary
opening for the expiratory tract the
downside of this is that there is no
filtration no humidification and no
temperature regulation through the oral
cavity but there is a plus side also
which is that that the oral cavity has a
wider opening so it facilitates greater
intake of air during exercise so till
now we have studied the air that we
inhale passes through our nasal cavity
or the oral cavity into the pharynx so
coming to the next important structure
in the human respiratory tract which is
the pharynx pharynx is basically a
muscular tube which lies behind the nose
in the mouth as well as the larynx and
it connects the oral and the nasal
cavity to the larynx as well as the
esophagus
now the part in the blue you see is the
part which is called the nasopharynx
this is the part which lies behind the
nasal cavity the second part of the
pharynx is called the oropharynx which
is the part in the green which lies
behind the oral cavity and the third is
called the laryngopharynx which lies
behind the larynx
so the air that we inhale through our
nose or to our oral cavity passes back
into the pharynx
when the air reaches the pharynx it has
two important structures where it can go
forward the first is the trachea which
lies in the front and second is the
esophagus which lies to the back
normally the air enters in the trachea
because II so figures at normal
conditions is a collapsed structure one
important structure to note here is the
epiglottis the epiglottis is basically a
cartilaginous structure which closes the
entry of the Phrygia and prevents entry
of food it is an elastic cartilage which
closes the laryngeal Inlet and prevents
entry of food into the trachea and
further the lungs the next important
structure in the respiratory tract is
the larynx the larynx
is located right here and it also known
as the voice box as well as the Adam's
apple the larynx is made up of many
cartilages and the larynx contains the
vocal cords the main functions of the
larynx in the human respiratory system
is that it connects the pharynx to the
trachea and the second important
structure is the production of sound or
speech the next important structure is
the trachea
so the trachea is basically a tube-like
structure which connects the larynx to
the bronchi and the bronchi in turn
connect to the lungs
if we take a closer look at the section
of the trachea we can see that the
trachea is basically made up of 20 C
shaped cartilages from above to below
these cartilages basically prevent the
collapse of the trachea because there is
a negative pressure in trachea as well
as the lungs during inhalation if you
see closely these tracheal rings are
basically C shaped these are not
completely circular because esophagus
lies behind the trachea and if these
rings were circular they would have
compressed to the east of Vegas during
swallowing and this could have led to
choking the trachea then divides into
the primary bronchi now this is called
the primary bronchi because it is the
first division of the trachea the
primary bronchi then divides into
secondary bronchioles
and then the secondary bronchioles
divide into the tertiary bronchioles and
what happens next
is that these tertiary bronchioles again
divide for about 20 divisions to form
the conducting bronchioles so you can
see the tertiary bronchioles divide many
times to form very small sac-like
structures the tertiary bronchioles lead
into the conducting bronchioles the
conducting bronchioles then form a 4 to
5 division series of respiratory
bronchioles these respiratory
bronchioles are in turn connected to the
alveoli
the alveoli are sac-like structures in
which the actual gas exchange happens
the conducting bronchioles are called
conducting bronchioles because no gas
exchange happens in them since they have
large or thick walls but raspberry
bronchioles have very thin walls and
some amount of gas exchange can happen
in these respiratory bronchioles but
majority of the gas exchange happens in
the alveoli because of their close
proximity to the blood vessels the
division of the bronchioles to such an
extent increases the effective surface
area of the lungs so the air that we
inhale finally reaches into the alveoli
now let's look at this diagram to
understand how the respiratory system of
her body works in conjunction with the
circulatory system to provide gas
exchange in this diagram you can see the
lungs the heart as well as a circulation
pool of the body showing the
deoxygenated blood in blue color as well
as the oxygenated blood in the pink onna
the heart receives all the deoxygenated
blood from the body through the superior
as well as the inferior vena cava this
blood has a low concentration of oxygen
and this is then pumped to the lungs
through the pulmonary arteries in the
lungs this deoxygenated blood is
subjected to gas exchange which converts
it into oxygenated blood which is pumped
back to the heart the heart then pumps
this oxygenated blood to the body which
utilizes the oxygen present in this
blood and again this blood is converted
into deoxygenated blood which is pumped
back to the heart the heart pumps all
the deoxygenated blood to the lungs
through two main arteries the right and
the left pulmonary artery just as we saw
with the previous branching pattern that
a single bronchus almost divides twenty
to twenty-five times before the
formation of alveoli the similar
phenomena happens with the large blood
vessels that enter into the lungs these
blood vessels also divide several times
which leads to formation of small
capillaries that are in extremely close
contact with the alveoli due to this the
cardiac output that comes in the large
vessels divides into many small streams
of blood this leads to exposure of the
five liters of blood coming through the
heart to almost 250 to 300 million
alveoli per minute due to this a rapid
gaseous exchange happens between the
alveolar air and the blood that is
exposed to the alveoli now let's try to
understand how the actual gas transport
happens inside a single ivi
so the air that we inhale passes through
a respiratory tract deep into our body
into a bunch of structures called
alveoli well this is important to create
a very less distance between the
alveolar air and the blood furnace
on this take a closer look at this
section of an ad villa which are
attached to the end of a respiratory
bronchioles you can see that a bunch of
alveoli are surrounded closely by blood
vessels if we take a single alveoli out
of this bunch and magnify it under
microscope we can see that the alveoli
is completely surrounded by a single
capillary but in reality they are
surrounded by multiple capillaries to
have very close contact with the blood
in these capillaries the deoxygenated
blood enters from one side it exchanges
the gases with the ovular air and
finally oxygenated blood is released
from the other side if we take a closer
look at the junction between the alveoli
and the capillary wall you can see that
the green side represents the space
inside the ad villi the cells in the sky
blue represent the alveolar epithelium
on the other side we have the blood
vessels which contain the RBC's and the
wall of the blood vessel is the
endothelium and between them is the
basement membrane which separates these
two cell layers so you can see clearly
that the air that we inhale in the
alveoli is a very close proximity which
is approximately few micrometers from
the blood vessel here comes a roll of
difference in the concentration of gases
on either side most of you know that the
diffusion occurs due to the difference
in concentration of a substance on
either side so if we take a look at the
concentration difference of the avila
air and the blood of carbon dioxide and
oxygen we can see that the alveolar air
has a low concentration of carbon
dioxide as compared to the blood which
has a higher concentration whereas
opposite of that is true in case of
oxygen where high concentration of
oxygen is present in alveolar air as
compared to low concentration of oxygen
in the blood due to this the high
concentration of carbon dioxide is
exchanged with the alveolar air and the
carbon dioxide is released outside in
the atmosphere whereas the fresh oxygen
that is coming through the alveolar air
is transported to the blood and blood is
made oxygenated so the blood coming on
one side of the capillary which is a
deoxygenated blood
is converted into oxygenated blood on
the other side this oxygenated blood is
then sent to the heart and the heart
then pumps this oxygenated blood to
whole of the body which is then utilized
so this was a brief description of the
human respiratory system I hope you
found this video helpful make sure to
help our channel by subscribing to our
YouTube channel and also make sure to
like our page for all the flashcards
mnemonics and upcoming stuff thank you
so much for watching